when people are trying to make  themselves look better by [ __ ] on  someone else they suck everyone thinks  by saying that person sucks or you're  the worst or i'm canceling you or you  [ __ ] suck miraculously that makes  them look better you want to look better  build other people up tearing other  people down  as a proxy to make yourself seem better  it's just like where is the civility and  the compassion and the kindness and  we're just so into shaming and it's just  time for more good it's just time to be  nice it's just time to care if  somebody's mean to you feel compassion  for them they're in a bad spot be the  bigger person we've completely lost the  ability to be the bigger person in the  face of [ __ ]